Governor Joe Lombardo making a trip to
Las Vegas today to highlight the
increase of violence in schools and to
promote a bill he believes is part of
the solution so it would Empower
teachers to take charge of the classroom
Joshua peguero has the details
Governor Jolo Barta was on Familiar
Grounds Friday visiting his alma mater
Valley High School to push assembly Bill
330. let me be clear
we don't need another any more victims
of school violence what we need is
serious reform and legislative action
accompanying the governor was Sade a
teacher sexually assaulted at El Dorado
High School Sade was not the first
victim of the heinous and horrific
School violence but we are fighting to
make her one of the last Lombardo's Bill
aims to change the 2019 restorative
justice law it has the backing of the
Clark County Education Association
teachers say the current law handcuffs
them in disciplining students yet ab330
would allow for expelling students who
assault staff or sell drugs and the
temporary removal of problem children
according to data I received from CCSD
there were about six arrests so far this
school year at Valley high school and
most of them were due to battery
assaults as well as fights Jody
Cunningham was one of the Valley High
teachers in attendance and she liked
what the governor had to say I'm all
about making a school safer this is my
job that I come to every day and I love
it and I love our kids here but it is
definitely harder when they're afraid
that some kind of violent act can happen
to them according to the governor there
has been a 46 increase in violence and
sexual assaults reported as CCSD since
2019 given those statistics I asked him
whether the district should be broken
well those efforts have failed to break
up the Clark County School District and
I don't think it's necessary for the
governor me specifically in the state of
Nevada to go to those extremes he adds
his bill will help avert efforts like
that Joshua peguero eight news now